tell me about your life what justifies
this what's happened to you that makes
you think you're justified in doing this
what do you tell me about my life well
you said you said you know anything
about your life tell me about yourself
because I'm getting trying to get on to
you because I'm black because I
guarantee you because you're black yeah
I guarantee you I don't give a damn
about yourself really no depends why
would you care of what color your skin
is I just think you're an idiot oh thank
you I think you're idiot too that's fine
you're perfectly entitled to yeah it's
about you so the show's called
uncensored I think you're an idiot for
what you've been doing I also think
you're an idiot for playing the race car
when no one's mentioned your skin color
really again you don't have to mention
it to her I don't care about your skin
color
I care about the fact that you've been
terrorizing all these people for a
sustained period of time I also care
about the fact you've only got a tiny
fine today no deterrent to you
whatsoever you don't show any real
remorse you don't really care you can
lose a week simple as the UK laws are
weak simple as and that's not mindful